yeah I hope you've noticed right and
I've got this built in to this process
right that the roots the intercepts on
the x-axis the roots are super super
important they really matter they tell
you a lot like 90 percent that's
interesting about this graph happens on
where the [ __ ] that you've work out
the rest from there okay but not all
words are the same they're not all
created equal
there are different kinds and I want to
tell you about three clients the most
important three they called single
double and triple roots okay now to
illustrate how they are different we are
going to look at these three example
curves because we know how to do all of
these curves we don't what they look
like they're very simple okay so you can
see I've just got a small set of axes
for each one we're going to draw it and
then we make some statements about it
okay
so y equals x if you had to describe y
equals x the graph it verbally to
someone how would you describe it its
its leader yeah it's a straight line
okay passes through the origin and it's
it's increasing its going up okay so I'm
going to draw that and you can draw one
as well doesn't have to be beautiful
okay but this you can see there's a root
at the origin right is that okay
no big deal we call this a single root
we're going to label all of these okay
and then I'm gonna add symbol language
to describe what's going on a y goes x
squared again it's a graph you're super
familiar with we it has a special name
that's a P it's caught up that's what I
mean to say it's a parabola right so
again let's draw this right it comes
down it stops it turns round like that
now again y equals x squared it has a
root at the origin okay but can you see
it's a different kind of Richmond right
because you know we had a look at this
it's like quadratics we expect them to
have two roots one here one here right
well this guy kinda has two roots as
well they just have to be both at the
same spot right they're both at x equals
zero so be that there are kind of two
sitting on the table we call the YZ
double words
no imagination for what's going to
happen next right we've seen is cubic
before okay again coming from the left
it uh starts at the bottom it goes up
and it comes up like that
this is called a triple root because
again a cubic you know like this cubic
or like this cubic we expect it to have
three roots and this one does have three
roots they just all happen to be at the
exact same spot at the Orangemen
at x equals zero so b but there are
three then we call it a triple root
killer you can see a few things number
one this language right single root
double root triple root what's really
referring to is the degree of the
coefficient sorry the degree of the
polynomial right if you got X to the one
you've got a single root X to the two
you've got two roots you've got X to
three you got three roots okay so that's
where that language comes from right now
how would we describe verbally what's
going on okay I've got some words here
that I hope hope will help you out
articulate what's happening right this
shaking what what is the graph doing as
it passes through the room well it just
sort of cuts straight through the actors
to see that it just slices right across
so in fact that's the way I say it cuts
through and keeps on going uninterrupted
okay yeah what do you have a look at
this one it doesn't just cut through
right in fact it does something quite
different it comes down it slows down it
just touches so you notice that it just
sort of hovers there and then it turns
around okay so the way that I would
explain this is that it touches the axis
it touches and then it turns okay that's
what a double root is doing you see it
comes to
it stops it goes back okay the last one
a triple root right it's starting from
one direction it stops there and pauses
for a minute but it doesn't turn around
like the double root does in fact it
just keeps on going after its pause
there okay so this cuts through this
touches and then it turns this guy the
way I said it is he pauses and then he
passes through right in the he was like
going in the same direction that he was
going before right and this one he's
going up threatened he goes up pauses
and then he keeps on going on right I
could just as easily have had a triple
root that went the other way that's
coming down and then he pauses and then
it keeps him going down so these three
categories of roots we can combine them
in all different kinds of ways and get
different kinds of graphs so let's
quickly do some very very brief examples
these are all going to be like kind of
um quick and dirty version so they don't
have to be very detailed okay well I'm
gonna give you quite a handful so first
two are really easy but just I want to
see that you understand this ID here
even from the most basic foundations
right so I'm looking for when I have
these are all factorize for you okay I'm
looking for the roots and whether they
are single roots double roots or triple
roots because then I can characterize
them and I can talk about how they're
behaving right so up here have a look at
that guy how many roots does he have he
has two here's one he's another one and
what kinds of roots are they they are
both single Bruce do you see that I mean
I could write one and one man okay so in
other words at x equals negative 1 and x
equals 1 it's on 1 negative 1 right the
graph is just going to cut through the
axis right cuz there's two single or is
this easy enough this is a parabola I
know what these look like they're no big
deal - sorry positive 1 and negative 1
so it just cuts through again have you
look at this how many roots are there
they are
one two three and each of them is a
single root you see that like the power
attached to each one is a one okay so
when I look at the numbers here I've got
negative 1 & 0 & 1 and I'm just going to
slice through I can do this this process
here the extremities to work out up
about down you can work that out in more
detail but just to get the general idea
you can see it's going to slice through
slice through slice through there's
those three single roots and each time
it cuts across the axis and just a stop
okay but here's now where it starts to
get more interesting have a look at this
guy right you can say like when I lost
the question how many roots topic you
can say this in one of two ways okay you
can either say up to the degree of the
whole polynomial it's the degree the
whole thing careful three now you see a
to depth the actual whole degree is 3
right they said do you need me or do you
okay so you can see the whole thing is
degree 3 right so I could say this
should be three roots right that's what
you expected a cubic is one right but
and all I can say it using this language
key is that they're in two roots is this
single group and this is a double root
right so I've got one at zero
there's my double root right there and
they don't have one at one someone in
particular just counting numbers oh sure
mmm yeah yeah come on Bukowski summit
yeah you own key period one yes yes that
kinis gonna come here at 10 past 9:00
who I was gonna have CSS period to
however it's gonna be short
it means 45 yeah could you get him to do
that joke in campaign yeah yeah that's
like whatever time that's all oh yeah
sure oh they're my friends down there if
you could just tell me what time it says
on that cop at the time I'll vomit from
they're all having geared to always you
know I'll take care oh nice okay guys
I'll quickly finish before you head out
to alcohol okay
now double root and zero usually all
that a single root at one now what's
this thing going to look like right well
I know by doing my extremities I'm going
to go negative and then positive so I'm
going to come up I'm gonna touch there
but because it's a double root it
touches and then turns around it comes
back down right but then he's got to
come back up to this single root right
and then just blow through like that you
see that double root single root touches
our turns cuts through keep up knowing
how did this go right how many roots are
there well I can either say there are
four roots or I can say is a double root
there at zero and there's a double root
here at careful lens to my suit very
good so what would this look like again
I will do my extremities okay I happen
to know that it's going to be positive
up here and positive member there I
think so he comes down and then he
touches but it's a double root so he
turns right but then he's got to come
back to this guy right so he's coming
back down he touches but it's a double
root so he turns right that looks a bit
weird doesn't it looks different other
once you've done before because the
power here is actually to the power of
four we're less familiar with this but
that doesn't mean we can't understand it
using these tools last one last one
I've got two kinds of Richie can you
tell me what kinds of root I have and
where they aren't
I've got a single brick at zero and then
I had a triple root at X equals 1 so 1 2
3 okay I do that just for myself like
you can't see it all really important
now I know from my extremities having
done this graph before that I'm going to
be coming from down from the bottom and
then I'm going to end at the bottom okay
now it's a single root here so he's just
going to pass through he's just gonna
cut through but he's got to come back to
this room now he comes back he touches
but because he's a triple root he pauses
and then he passes through in the same
direction you seen that he doesn't turn
back like a double root it's a triple
root that's why he ends up down okay
we're gonna look at some hot examples on
Thursday and then we're done